[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
other like trials or an idiot do me a
favor can teach us to be a friendly into
the neighborhood spider-man just stay
close to the ground just a spider-man
from your - hey everyone
tom volunteer I am your new spider-man
in the new spider-man homecoming movie I
just want to let you in on a little
secret on May 6th there will be a free
giveaway of loads of different comics at
your local comic book store make sure
you find out the local participating
stores make sure you grab a copy of the
new specter of spider-man and also make
sure that you check out spider-man
homecoming is this is - license
thank you thank you
hey everybody so if you're wondering why
they're using spider-man homecoming to
promote Free Comic Book Day it's because
there's a brand new spectacular
spider-man comic book that's launching
they have a special secret Empire comic
book that everyone is freaking out about
and a lot of you have been asking me
about Marvel legacy in the big marvel
rebirth that's going to be happening
later this year so I'll explain
everything starting with the new
spider-man stuff but there is a
spider-man giveaway happening all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video it's for
the action figures not for the comics
that says they really get you comics
might cost 399 for 99 the toys of what
really get you so the spider-man of
spider-man homecoming is the friendly
neighborhood spider-man as described by
Tony Stark hey why don't you be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man don't
worry about being an Avenger right now
well they're actually debuting a new
spectacular spider-man comic book where
he is going to be more of a friendly
neighborhood spider-man now if you
haven't been reading the spider-man
comics just quick explainer he's
actually much older in the comics the
amazing spider-man comic book is the
main title he's actually taken over the
Fantastic Four's Baxter building there
was a really funny dr. doom moment in
last week's comic book where he got
super upset by this
so spider-man in the comics right now is
more of a Tony Stark type character he's
a billionaire he has a company called
Parker industries so he is so far from
the spider-man that you're going to be
seeing in spider-man homecoming in the
character starting to fall apart
and lose his way so he's getting back to
his roots by becoming a friendly
neighborhood spider-man and it's going
to be a more intimate story where he's
not globe-trotting
all over the world with big
billion-dollar adventures is going to
feel more like the spider-man that
you're going to see in spider-man
homecoming the Tom Holland version of
the character and the issue is actually
inside the secret Empire Free Comic Book
Day comic so if you didn't know Free
Comic Book Day is a day where they give
away surprise surprise free comic books
you have to go to that Free Comic Book
Day website to check the locator to find
a shop near you that's actually
participating where you can get these
free comics but the real reason that
people are freaking out and Nick Spencer
actually tweeted about this at the last
big comic book convention in Chicago
where he was chuckling a little bit
because somebody got to look at the
secret Empire free comic book day comic
in the last page was a huge spoiler but
it made the grown man that was reading
it scream out loud so it's a big spoiler
so I'll say spoiler warning for the end
of the free comic book day secret empire
story so I'll explain why everyone is so
upset and how this ties in with what's
going on with the larger problems at
Marvel in what Marvel legacy is going to
do about that or hopefully do about that
so the reason that grown man screamed is
because the Hydra Captain America was
able to wield Thor's hammer meaning that
what you know whatever the twist is
behind Hydra Captain America he's deemed
worthy by mule near so everyone's like
wait a minute
why is Hydra Captain America who is the
worst character in the Marvel Universe
right now he did a complete takeover of
the world
why is he worthy upholding Thor's hammer
because even though he's not a Nazi he's
kind of like a Nazi so it's really
upsetting and really confusing because
he seems like the character that is
least worthy of wielding Mjolnir because
it's almost like saying that he's good
for bringing Hydra back and even though
there's this big complicated explanation
for what this version of Hydra is versus
the red skulls version of Hydra they're
trying to explain it as Hydra being this
ancient order which they kind of did on
agents of shield something that predated
the Nazis and them was hijacked by them
but at the end of the day they still
kind of come off like Nazis so if you
want to find out wTF is going on with
this big twist the only way to get this
comic book is to actually go to a comic
book shop during free comic book day the
marvel legacy stuff that everybody is
talking about is completely separate so
there's this big thing that's happened
to last year with Marvel's all-new
all-different in the fact that it's got
like a billion different titles for each
character that sort of diluted their
sales in virtually all the legacy
characters like Steve Rogers Captain
America Tony Stark Iron Man are not in
their main comic books so everybody's
really upset at Marvel for a bunch of
different reasons so there's this Marvel
generations event that's leading into
Marvel legacy where as the name implies
you have the young all-new all-different
characters meeting up with the older
legacy characters and then Marvel legacy
is like the official bringing back of
one really big character which I have a
pretty good idea of
but Marvel legacy is them just bringing
back Tony Stark Iron Man bringing back
Wolverine bringing back the main
versions of the characters to their main
comic books so the idea is that will
course correct without them getting rid
of all the new characters that they
introduced so part of the idea is that
they feel like everybody is really upset
and not buying Marvel comics because
they're so different and they change
things so quickly so the bringing back
most of the old stuff that they change
but it's basically like their version of
rebirth but it's not quite as drastic as
that but a lot of people feel like
that's what it's going to take to fix
Marvel Comics but it's part of a much
larger issue with Marvel diluting its
sales by releasing too many versions of
a different character in comic books
each month so there are four different
spider-man titles each month or four
different Avengers titles then fewer
people are going to buy that one main
Avengers comic book or main spider-man
comic book so really more than anything
that's hurting their sales because there
are so many comic books that Marvel is
pushing out each month part of the thing
that DC has going for it right now is
that like the flash is a really big
character the comic book is selling
really well but how many flash comic
books are there each month there's one
flash comic book so if you're a flash
fan you only have to buy one comic book
you don't have to buy four comic books
so they're not diluting their sales
quite as much as Marvel is in the thing
about that is there actually is a big
flash comic book the Batman crossover
I'll be doing a video for that later
today because it is crazy
it was an amazing comic book so if you
guys do want me to do specific comic
book videos just leave all your requests
in the comments below
but hopefully that explains a little bit
about what's going on with Marvel legacy
in the really big character that they're
bringing back that they say is going to
break the internet I think is the main
version of Reed Richards and they'll
bring the Fantastic Four back is a
family because right now the Fantastic
Four don't exist Ben Grimm is part of
the comics and there's a version of Reed
Richards but I don't think it's the main
version sue Richards the rest of the
family isn't around so I think they're
going to bring them back because they
say they're bringing a big Marvel
mainstay back so leave all your theories
in the comments below who is the big
character that Marvel Comics is bringing
back that's supposed to break the
internet whether or not it actually
breaks the internet remains to be seen
so if they can
relations to the latest giveaway winner
Khan Wu 76 you win the Spider Man action
figures from my last video please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there'll also be a new
flash giveaway when I post that Flash
Batman video and a couple hours later
today while you wait for that you can
click here for that Avengers infinity
War part 2 teaser where we learn a
little bit about what's going on with
the fourth Avengers film and you can
click here for another brand new
spider-man homecoming promo thank you so
much for watching let's have fun I'll
see you guys in the next video
you